rain and cooler temperatures are
bringing some relief this morning for
communities devastated by the
out-of-control
buh buh fires rather raging across
Australia at least 25 people have died
as a result of the fire since September
and it's estimated nearly half a billion
animals with a B are also dead nearly 20
million acres have burned there and
authorities say the fires could keep
burning for months Jamie yuccas is on
the scene of the Australian capital of
Canberra Jamie when I first heard
half-a-billion honestly I thought it was
a typo so I'm curious about what
conditions are like they're clearly not
very good
that's right Gayle it's astonishing
what's happening in this country here in
the capital of Canberra I can tell you
that earlier today the people had a deal
with the worst air quality of any major
city in the world it still smells very
strongly of smoke my crew and I drove
from Sydney which is about three and a
half hours away and what we saw were
rural towns devastated we cannot
guarantee your safety
at present authorities across Southeast
Australia are racing to get people to
safety using the light rain and cool
weather for cover after supercharge
fires continue to ravage the continent
over the weekend the fires have scorched
nearly 20 million acres of land forcing
thousands to flee my neighbor stayed to
defend his property and he contacted me
this morning fire officials here in New
South Wales say the flames roared
through here so quickly that the fire
consumed things like cars homes and
vegetation at a rate of seven miles in
two hours Australian firefighters are
working around the clock babbling both
the fierce flames and exhaustion all the
craziness area just hurting it's hard as
a crew of us firefighters arrived to
provide welcomed assistance did you ever
think you'd see something of this
magnitude in Australia never never a
vacuum Margaret Fitzpatrick came back to
find both her neighbors homes burned
down but hers still standing for people
watching in the United States what would
you want them to know just the spirit of
everyone
banding together and helping each other
and even though a lot of people have
lost a lot of things we still have that
really good community spirit the
Australian Government has committed the
equivalent to one and a half billion
u.s. dollars for recovery efforts
firefighters did have the upper hand
today and better conditions tomorrow but
later this week they're very concerned
about stronger winds and higher
temperatures
those look like something out of a
horror movie Jamie yuccas and Australia
thanks
you